Once your rig becomes a bit more complex, you might find that you spend a bit of time
customizing the look and the position of your controls, and you might want to consider how
you can speed up some of that workflow so that you're not repeating the same steps every
time you make a new control.
Something that works really well here is initially setting up the controls for one-half of your
body and then using the mirror function to copy and mirror all of the controls to the
other side.
Now, this will save you a lot of time when you're setting up your controls and it maintains
how you've customized the look of the money copies them over.
So let's take a look at how to mirror some controls.
We have a slightly more complex rig here where, as you can see, we've set up the controls
on one-half of the body and for each of the controls, we have customized them in a different
way.
So they're a different color and they're a different shape.
And we're going to mirror these over from the character's right-hand side to the left
side.
So to do that, if we select all of our controls by shift-selecting, right-click and then choose
mirror.
And this is going to ask you, what axis do you want to mirror the controls across?
And if we look at our little gizmo down here, we want to mirror along the x-axis, so this
is correct, and we want to flip along the z-axis, so we want to flip them 180 along
that vertical axis.
So the axis to flip is also correct.
Now the search and replace options are to do with the naming of the controls.
So currently, because this is the right side, within the control name, you can see we have
underscore R underscore.
I'm going to copy and replace with underscore L underscore.
So in search, we put underscore R underscore and replace underscore L underscore.
When we hit OK, you can see that our controls are mirrored across from left to right.
They look exactly the same, they're the same color and same shapes and any sort of positional
updates we've made to the shapes transforms, you can see they've been updated as well.
Now we need to make sure that our controls transforms are matching with their corresponding
bones.
And to test whether or not the controls are aligned with the bones transforms, there's
a nice way to visualize this.
So if I search for upper arm, for example, we know that this upper left-hand arm is the
one that we've just created a new control for with the mirror function.
And if we right-click and choose control bone transform, we can see with our manipulator
handle here, our gizmo, that we've got the x-axis pointing down the bone, the y-forward
and the z-sort of up to the right-hand side here.
Now if I select the control we just created, you can see that that's flipped slightly.
So what you'll find is that the same thing has happened with each of these controls
that we've created.
So the position in space will be correct, but the orientation might be flipped.
So we choose the lower arm, right-click, control bone transform, and then if I select the control,
you'll see that this flips slightly.
So what we need to do here is set out offset transforms from the closest bone, like we
did with the controls in the other rig.
But if we do that while all of the controls are in hierarchy, you'll find that things
go a little bit wonky.
So I'll just show you an example of this.
If I select all of these controls here, I choose right-click and then set offset from
closest bone, you'll see that the controls kind of jump around all over the place.
And that's because the parent is having an effect on each of the children.
So if I control Z to undo that, if I select each control and press Shift P, you could
also select multiple controls together and press Shift P. That will bring them out of
the hierarchy.
We can then select all of our left side controls, if I zoom out a little bit here.
Right-click, set offset transforms from closest bone, and you can see that the controls haven't
moved their world position, but the orientations have updated to match the bones.
So now if we just fix the hierarchy again, putting our arms and legs back together, if
we were to select the upper arm, for example, right-click, control bone transform, we can
see that it's still set up the same way that it was, so X pointing down the bone, Y forwards.
And if we now select our upper arm, control, you'll see that set up exactly the same way,
which means that when you set up your logic, everything should work correctly.
Coming back to our basic IK setup here, what I've done is I've used the mirror function
to duplicate and mirror our hand and our pole vector controls from the right-hand side to
the left-hand side.
Now I wanted to show you one more thing in relation to mirroring that's available on
the basic IK node itself, and this might speed you up when you're setting up the rest
of your rig logic.
If we duplicate our node here, what you can do is right-click the node itself towards
the top here and choose search and replace mirror.
And this will give us the same sort of mirror options that we had when right-clicking in
the rig hierarchy.
So we want the same options again, we want to mirror along the X axis and then flip along
the Z axis.
This time we're searching and replacing the name of the bones that we have inside the
node here.
So we'll search for underscore R and we want to replace with underscore L.
And when we hit OK, you'll see that these bone names update inside the node.
And then we just need to create the same setup as we have with the other basic IK node.
So drag these two controls in and choose get control.
Remember that our transform of our hand control is going to go into the effector pin and the
translation of our pole vector node is going to plug into pole vector.
And something we want to do as well because it's mirrored is change our primary axis from
minus one to one and then also flip our secondary axis from one to minus one.
And when we connect up the logic and hit compile, if I select our left hand control here, you'll
see that we now have two IK hand controls working pretty quickly after just updating
a few mirror search and replace options and copying over the right hand controls to the
left hand side.
The last thing we're going to look at is setting up some sort of aim control using the aim
function.
And this is a really handy tool if you want part of your skeletal mesh to always point
towards something.
So that could be creating a head look system for your character or maybe something like
making the turret of a gun always point towards a target.
So the aim function works a lot like the pole vector setup we had just a moment ago.
Now we need to tell the function what bone we want to affect and give it a control as
a target to aim at.
And then make sure that we have our primary and secondary axes set up correctly.
So if I come back to our rig graph here, right click and search for aim.
This is the aim function that we're going to use.
Now we need to give our aim function something to target at.
So I'm going to select our head bone, right click, new control.
Put that inside the hierarchy of our root control.
And the same as we did with the pole vector, I'm just going to drag this out along the
y-axis.
Right click and choose set offset transform from current.
So back to the aim node.
The bone that we're trying to control is going to be the head.
And our target, if I drag our head control in here, is going to be the position of our
head control.
So if we plug our translation pin in here to our target pin there, and then I'll connect
up the logic.
And you can see already we're aiming towards our control, but again we haven't quite got
the primary and secondary axes correct.
So if I select our head control, or our head bone should I say, and press F to zoom in on
that.
Just so we're not getting some misleading results here, I'm going to disconnect the logic
to get it back to its default pose.
And we can see that our y-axis is pointing in the positive direction.
So that'll be our primary axis.
So underneath the axis tab here, we'll change x to zero and then y to one.
And underneath the secondary axis tab here, we're currently set to Z.
Now this is our up axis, or the axis that's pointing towards this bone's parent.
So if we select the head here, and I just zoom in a bit, we can see that the pointing
towards our parent is the negative x-axis.
So if I put negative one inside here, and then zero in there, whoops not ten, zero.
And then reconnect up the logic.
When we compile, you can see that the head is pointing in the right direction.
And when we move the head control here, our head continues to point towards it.
And this is super super useful for things like setting up a head control system like
I mentioned earlier.
Or even just animating your character's head to look left and right, and always aim towards
something maybe as they're walking around.
Now that we've seen how to create a simple FK setup and a simple IK setup, as well as
using the aim function to give your character a target to always aim towards, let's go
into sequencer and see how we can now animate with it.
There are two ways we can get started with our animation.
The first would be to grab our control rig here and drag it straight into the level.
And what this will do is create a new level sequence for us, including our character and
the rig that's connected to them.
The second way we could do this is to add our character to a pre-existing sequence.
So if I come back to the content browser, we have a pre-existing sequence here called
my level sequence.
Double click that to open it.
Come back to our content browser.
I can grab our character mesh here and I can click and hold and drag it on top of the
sequencer window here.
That gives us a new character and also includes a control rig with the character.
Now this isn't the control rig that we initially created.
So we'd have to delete that control rig by highlighting and press delete.
We could hit the plus next to our character's name here.
Come to control rig and go into untick filter asset by skeleton and search for the control
rig that we just created, which is skm quen simple control rig.
Now there's one big difference when you add assets to sequences in these two different
ways.
If you drag them in from the content browser like we just did, that asset becomes what's
known as spawnable and it only exists in the level when you have the sequence open.
This is great for if you're working with some sort of shot based workflow.
When you add an asset to the sequencer from the level instead, these assets are known as
possessible, which means they are persistent within the level and you need to have the
level open for the sequencer to reference that asset.
This is useful if you have multiple level sequences that want to reference the same
asset.
An indication of a spawnable asset will be inside the sequence here where you see the
lightning bolt icon.
If we open our sequence that was created when we dragged the control rig into the level,
you'll see that this character doesn't have that icon.
So this character is possessible, meaning that the sequence is referencing this character
saved in the level.
So let's get started with our animation.
I'm going to briefly go over some of the core components of a sequencer so we know how to
select our controls and how to set a key on those controls and then how to bake our animation
out and save that as its own animation sequence.
So as you can see, we have our control rig track just inside the sequencer here.
And if I pop that open, this shows us all the controls that are inside that control
rig.
Let's just zoom in on our character a little bit here.
Now I could select the controls from inside the sequence here, which isn't too bad if
you've only got a few controls, but this list can get quite long.
So you can also select them from the viewport or from the anim outliner here.
Now to set a key on our controls, we could set a key on everything in the control rig
by hitting this plus on the parent track.
Or if you just want to add a key to individual controls, you would just use the plus on the
individual control track.
So let's set a key on everything with the plus here.
And what we're going to do is just make a simple animation of our character waving.
Now something that's really useful to turn on here that we already have active currently
is auto key.
So whenever you make a change to a control, whether that's translating it or rotating
it, what auto key is going to do is set a key when you make that change.
So we've dragged our time slider across here.
And what I'm going to do is grab our control here, bring it up in the viewport and just
rotate it so it looks like the start of a wave.
Now something to make working with control rig a little easier in the viewport.
Under the animation tab here, you can turn on select, which only selects the control
rig controls.
So if we activate that, now when I click on the mesh or the skydome, none of this gets
selected, which is just super handy so that you can only select the controls and you don't
accidentally select a mesh or something else in the viewport.
But if I select our control again, come along a little further and we'll just make our wave
animation.
And I think what we might do here is if we grab the head control, we could have that
look towards us on the camera over here.
And then if we set a key again, we could bring that back to default just by resetting
all the location values and the same with the hand here to finish off our animation.
So if we play this animation back, we've got a quick wave and a head look over here
that we can now save out as its own animation sequence and use elsewhere in the project.
So if I press this little red button here, what that's going to do is bring the end of
the playback range down to where my time slider is.
And if we scroll up to select our character here, right click and choose bake animation
sequence.
This will then bake the animation down to its own animation sequence that we could use
elsewhere in the project.
So if I just use the content browser as the default location to save this and I just call
this a underscore wave and hit OK, we get another option box comes up and depending
whether or not any of these properties are relevant to your character like having morph
targets or material curves or anything, you can tick these on and off.
For now, I'll just leave them at default and choose export to animation sequence.
Now if we go back to our content browser, inside the default content folder is our wave
that we just created.
And we can see our character waving to us, looking at us and then going back to the default
pose.
And that's it.
So you can now access this animation as an animation sequence or bring it back into sequence
and edit it further and then use elsewhere in your project.
Hopefully you now have an understanding of how control rig works and how to set up a
simple FK and IK rig as well as learning how to create a name target for your rig and
then animate it in sequencer.
We have more courses that cover rigging in much more depth as well as animating in sequencer.
So if those are some skills that you want to develop, be sure to check those out.
But for now, good luck with your rigging and animating.